okay today I'm going to talk to you
about the structure of an atom so we're
going to know learn about protons
neutrons and electrons and how we can
use the periodic table to figure out how
many of each of these subatomic
particles are in each essence so first
of all let's have a look at the periodic
table as we can see for all of these
different elements they have two numbers
one of them the bigger one is called the
mass number the bottom one is called the
atomic number also known as a proton
number so we can see that each of
furniture firm they've got different
numbers and that tells us about the
number of protons neutrons and electrons
that are within each acid so let's have
a look at an example so one of the
elements within the periodic table is
lithium it has these two numbers 7 & 3
so first of all this smaller number here
is called the atomic number it's also
sometimes called the proton number as
well
now easy to remember this the proton
number tells us how many protons there
are so this particular element because
it has a proton number of three we know
that it has three protons now I know
that protons are positive so protons are
my positive and sub atomic particles
what a subatomic particle if it is a
particle smaller than an atom
so it has three protons I know that it
also has three electrons because in any
atom before any electrons have been
transferred or anything like that my
number of positive protons will always
balance out with my number of negative
electrons so if I've got three protons
I'm going to have three electrons okay
moving on to the mass number
so this here is called the mass number
now if the way I remember that this is
called the mass number if this number is
bigger than the atomic number so I think
of mass I think of massive I know that
this number is bigger the mass number
tells us the number of protons plus our
number of neutrons plus our number of
neutrons these are the two particles
that we find in the nucleus of an atom
so if this mass number is seven I can
figure out how many neutrons
I've got by doing seven because there's
seven protons and neutrons so 37 take
away three because there's I know
there's three protons because that's my
proton number that tells me how many
neutrons I've got so I've got four
neutrons now I know that neutrons have
are neutral which means they don't have
any charge at all so the start of these
these words can help me with that so
what I need to do now is I need to know
whereabouts in an atom each of these are
located now
this mass number this number here tells
us the number of particles in the
nucleus protons and neutrons we find in
the nucleus so I know I've got 3 protons
1 2 3 and I know that I have 4 neutrons
1 2 3 4 so in the nucleus the center
part of the atom that's where I find
these particles now electrons go in
shells around the nucleus and and they
were raised in a certain way that we're
not going to go through in this
particular video but as you can see
we've got 3 electrons so in the first
shell I've got 2 and in the next one
I've got my third one
so quick recap atoms are made of protons
neutrons and electrons protons are
positive neutrons are neutral and
electrons are negative the atomic number
tells us the number of protons it also
tells the number of electrons the mass
number tells number of protons added to
the number of neutrons so to find the
number of neutrons we take the mass
number and we take away the proton
number protons and neutrons go in the
nucleus electrons go in shells around
the outside thank you